We're seeing another stimulus, possibly calmed down to pike. And I was like,
if they had just done the basic income thing that Andrew Yang was running on,
maybe this wouldn't be such a horrific time to be here in this country.
You're a hundred percent right. Karen,
where unfortunately now we're in like this pandemic fueled a recession that
could become a depression and we need to get money into people's hands.
So I've been doing my best to both make that case to members of Congress.
There's an emergency cash relief bill that literally 74% of Americans
support does getting money into our hands. Uh, can you think of something else,
74% of Americans support at this point? Like what do you,
what do you have to do to try and get that higher?
A majority of Republicans and Democrats.
So let's talk some sense into our legislators and get economic
relief into our hands. I wish it didn't have to be like in this, uh,
tragic and devastating a time, but it's overdue.
Well, Jack Dorsey, the CEO of Twitter just announced that he's, uh,
donating $3 million to those mayors. Uh,
I think the mayor in California Stockton has been doing it
successfully. So he was one of the leading ones, chocolate Lumumba,
Keisha Lance bottoms is a bunch of mayors.
Veronica, you know, a bunch of people. Um,
I was on a panel with mayor Tubbs of Stockton, uh,
last year and he said something to me. I probably,
probably not supposed to share, but I'll share it because you know,
whatever we're here. Um, but he said to me, after the panel, he said like,
Andrew, you can say. I could never get away with saying,
okay. And what he meant by that was that like, I was just up there being like,
look, we have to value people, intrinsically have to get,
give everyone a basic income and the rest of it. And last year he was like,
if a young black mayor were to say that, like people would be like,
what the heck are you talking about? He's like, but now it's not just him.
It's Keisha Lance bottoms. It's Ross, Baraka and Newark. Uh,
it's mayors around the country and they're going to be many more because if
you're a mayor and you see what's happening in your community,
you're going to say like, wait a minute. Like we need to do things differently.
So, so tell me what the disconnect is. And I've watched it around welfare.
I've watched it.
There's like this notion in this country that if we give somebody something that
somehow it takes something away from me. And so it is a weird thing,
but I literally watched the government print money,
trillions of dollars and give it to people and no one had a problem with it.
And I'm like, Oh, so we could just print money and just give it to people.
Well, we could have been doing it the whole time. Karen,
I asked that brutal truth. And Martin Luther King saw this in the sixties.
He was like, we should have a basic income today.
And he was killed while he was making that case.
And somehow we've been brainwashed into this nonsense myth that like, Oh,
we don't have enough to go around. It's been nonsense for a long time.
And this pandemic has demonstrated to all of us when push came to shove,
like you just said,
did we just $4 trillion for wall street when they needed a bailout? Yes.
Did we just print $4 trillion for big companies?
And to some extent ourselves, like during this pandemic, yes, we can do it.
We just need enough members of Congress to get on board with the fact that they
work for us. They don't work for Amazon.
They don't work for the giant companies that have been laughing their way,
all the way to the bank for the last number of years and decades.
When, when you were talking about universal, basic income is, you know,
during the election cycle, et cetera. Um,
I was always wondering like,
where are there other places that actually made it work?
And you're given a couple of examples,
like even I saw recently that you had tweeted about how that work
is on it.
It's on its way to creating a floor for universal income. Right?
Talk about where the rest of the world he is on this.
Because I think it's such a foreign concept to so many, uh,
so many Americans that they think it's not possible. Right.
But there are precedents for this,
like literally in places throughout the world.
Yeah.
South Africa just announced that they're going to make it happen for everyone.
Uh, India is actually implementing a version of it, uh,
to tens hundreds of millions of people, Canada.
They did like a full on UBI trial and an entire town for years.
And in that town, you saw better health, mental health, more people,
starting businesses, more people going back to school. It was beautiful.
And when they found that data, they were like, this is,
this is exactly what we should have been doing this entire time.
Like the data is like Indiana Jones, you know,
like rate as the lost Ark where like the data was like,
it's a freaking warehouse or filing cabinet where people were
trying to keep it from public eye. But then when they found it, they were like,
Oh my gosh. Like, so they're like you said,
there are examples of this happening around the world.
And the most compelling example,
I think tens of millions of Americans just experiences,
like everyone got 1200 bucks and everyone liked it, loved it.
Like it didn't make anyone, all of a sudden being like, Oh,
like work is for like losers or something.
Been shut down because you gave its citizens their money back, right?
Like government didn't stop because we gave citizens some of their money back.
Right? Yeah. And it helped the economy greatly. It like reduce the poverty rate,
but it also went back right into local businesses to groceries, to fuel,
to rent. Uh,
and we are the citizens and the re the stakeholders of the richest society in
the history of the world, like $22 trillion pre crisis,
we can a hundred percent afford this. Dr. King knew it in the sixties.
He was like, we can afford this. Now he was right.
Then it's even more true today than it was. Then
it's so baffling that.
There's so much resistance. And it's always around this notion of laziness,
this myth of laziness that will somehow, you know,
lull people into not getting up and pulling herself themselves up by the
bootstrap. We're talking with two Andrews, Andrew McCaskill, of course,
Andrew Yang.
You also are out talking about police reform and cash
relief. Talk a little bit about what, what it is. You're proposing Andrew Yang.
On the police reform style side of things.
I looked at the data because I'm a data guy, Karen, uh,
and the data is shocking where you're seeing cities around the
country pound over a billion dollars a year in civil suits for police misconduct
and brutality, uh,
and the legal standard to successfully Sue a police officer is very high.
So if you were seeing successful suits at over a billion dollars a year,
you know that the magnitude of the problem is multiple billions of dollars.
And this is literally bankrupting,
some towns where some cop does something reprehensible,
and then the entire police department gets now at this point,
you have to look at it and say,
this is a rampant problem in is like many of the problems we're talking about
has been in place for years.
And when I talked to a black lives matter activists about this,
he actually hit the nail on the head. He said, look,
local DA's cannot control cops in their area,
because if you're the da in that area,
you literally rely upon law enforcement every day,
just to do your job and make cases.
And then for you to turn around and being like, Hey, bad cops,
like we're going to bust you all. But like the,
the local da is like Kamala Harris case at the same thing, she was like,
you know, you cannot expect the locals to do this. So what I proposed, uh,
was that you need a federal department of justice commission that ideally be
named after George Floyd, that all their mission was,
was to investigate issues around police misconduct. And if you're a local da,
you would celebrate because finally it would be something that's off your plate.
And you know that there are issues, you know, there are bad cops in your area,
but you can't do much about it. And then you can just say,
look like give it to the feds. And then the feds come in.
I guess the only way that you would actually be able to address this issue,
in my opinion, uh, around the country in a real way,
that would actually stand up over time. Thank you for listening in.
I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.